programming throwdown episode 52 scientific python take it away patrick virtual reality when we're recording this podcast, we're, I think, just after the Game Developers Conference, and so there's been a lot of tech news buzz about virtual reality and all the cool, awesome demos people have of their games and projects that run in virtual reality. So I thought this would be a good opportunity to talk about it. Personally, I've never gotten the chance to use any of the new generation,
Programming Throwdown 第52期，科学 Python。帕特里克，开始吧。虚拟现实。我们录制这期播客时，我想应该是在游戏开发者大会（GDC）之后，所以关于虚拟现实以及人们在虚拟现实中运行的游戏和项目所展示的那些酷炫、令人惊叹的演示，有很多科技新闻热点。所以我认为这是一个谈论它的好机会。就我个人而言，我从来没有机会使用任何新一代的产品，
the Vive or the, I guess Sony has one now, or the Oculus Rift. But I hear it's a very awesome experience and I'm starting to see videos that make me excited to try it. And I know virtual reality is always supposed to have been the next big thing for a while now. But I feel like it might actually happen this time.
比如 Vive，或者我想索尼现在也有一款，又或者是 Oculus Rift。但我听说这是一种非常棒的体验，而且我开始看到一些让我兴奋得想去尝试的视频。我知道虚拟现实一直以来都被认为是下一个大事件，但我感觉这一次它可能真的要实现了。
Or maybe it'll just fizzle and then they'll give up on it forever. Jason, have you tried, actually gotten to try any virtual reality headsets? I have. I tried the Oculus. It's pretty cool. One of the big things that I think I'm still waiting for, I mean, I'm obviously a huge gamer, right? And so the gaming part of it, I think is cool. But what I really want is actually a way to like produce content, VR content. I mean, right now, almost all the content is synthetic. It's all video games,
或者它可能只是昙花一现，然后人们就永远放弃它了。杰森，你试过吗？真的有机会尝试过任何虚拟现实头显吗？我试过。我试过 Oculus。它真的很酷。我认为我还在等待的一件大事是——我的意思是，我显然是个超级游戏玩家，对吧？所以我觉得游戏部分很酷。但我真正想要的是一种能够制作内容的方式，VR 内容。我的意思是，现在几乎所有的内容都是合成的。全都是电子游戏，
you know, rendered. But it'd be amazing if, you know, you could just, like, set up a bunch of cameras in your living room and then, you know, put your newborn baby or toddler or something in the living room and your parents could just kind of walk around. Like, you know, your parents would be maybe in, you know, Australia or something, but they could walk around the living room doesn't that require either like a robot or something like computational photography like i had you're taking a light field picture or whatever some weird multi-camera pictures and then computationally adjusting for a virtual camera location yeah i mean i mean what i'm... Like, what I envision is, like, you put a bunch of cameras in your living room, and then they build, like, a 3D representation of the living room, including, like, the table and everything. Yeah, I don't really know much about how that would actually work.
你知道，渲染出来的。但如果能像这样就太棒了：你可以在客厅里架设一堆摄像头，然后把你刚出生的婴儿或蹒跚学步的孩子放在客厅里，你的父母就可以四处走动。就像，你知道，你的父母可能在澳大利亚什么的，但他们可以在客厅里走动。那不需要机器人或者像计算摄影之类的东西吗？比如你拍摄光场照片或者其他什么奇怪的多摄像头照片，然后通过计算来调整虚拟摄像机的位置。是的，我的意思是……我所设想的是，你在客厅里放一堆摄像头，然后它们构建出一个客厅的 3D 表现形式，包括桌子和所有东西。是的，我不太清楚这实际上是如何运作的。
But, yeah, I'm sorry I'm, like, kind of making up the technology, but I just want the ability for the content to be real instead of synthetic so you tried the oculus rift and one of the things about at least i think but currently about the oculus rift is it tracks where your head is but you can't like like if you get up and walk forward it doesn't know you walked forward uh right right okay and then the difference between the vive and i had to look it up that's how how it was pronounced, like Vive, Vive. The HTC Vive is it actually has cameras in the room that track where you are.
但是，是的，抱歉，我有点在编造这项技术，但我只是希望内容能够是真实的，而不是合成的。所以你试过 Oculus Rift，我认为至少目前关于 Oculus Rift 的一点是，它会追踪你的头部位置，但你不能像……比如如果你站起来向前走，它不知道你向前走了。呃，对，对，好的。然后 Vive 和——我得查一下，那是它的发音方式，像 Vive，Vive。HTC Vive 的区别在于，它实际上在房间里有摄像头来追踪你的位置。
So you can actually like lean, move left, like strafe left to strafe right, walk forward. Oh, really? Yeah, and then like it puts up, or at least in the demo I was seeing, like it was putting up indications when you got close to your actual wall. Like you teach it the boundaries of your space. Oh, so you got close to your actual wall. You teach it the boundaries
所以你实际上可以倾斜、向左移动，比如向左平移、向右平移、向前走。哦，真的吗？是的，然后它会显示，或者至少在我看到的演示中，当你靠近实际墙壁时，它会发出提示。就像你教它空间的边界一样。哦，所以你靠近了实际的墙壁。你教它空间的边界，
of your space. So you don't run into the wall. Because you can't see. It's not augmented reality. It's actual virtual reality. Right. I think that's kind of cool, but that's going to be a drastic change. Because I don't have as much time as I used to.
这样你就不会撞到墙上。因为你看不到。这不是增强现实。这是真正的虚拟现实。对。我觉得这很酷，但这将是一个巨大的改变。因为我没有以前那么多的时间了。
But I remember being able to play for just hours and hours at a time. But if you're standing up, obviously, like, that will probably get tired because, let's face it, I don't think most gamers are in shape. I mean, you know, there are other games like there's, you know, DDR where you have to, like, you know, like stomp on some foot pedals. There's the Wii.
但我记得曾经能够一次玩上好几个小时。但如果你是站着的，显然，这可能会让人疲劳，因为面对现实吧，我不认为大多数游戏玩家身体素质很好。我的意思是，你知道，还有其他游戏，比如 DDR，你必须，你知道，跺脚踩踏板。还有 Wii。
In the Wii, you kind of have to be standing. So I do think that there have been in the past games where you have to be active. But do people play them in the same amount of hours as like a Skyrim? Oh, no, probably not, right? I mean, maybe DDR, yeah, like a very, very few amount of people
在 Wii 上，你基本上得站着。所以我确实认为过去有一些游戏是需要你保持活跃的。但人们玩它们的时间会像玩《上古卷轴》那样长吗？哦，不，可能不会，对吧？我的意思是，也许 DDR 会，是的，极少数人，
over i mean yeah ddr i mean i used to play ddr in college and yeah you really you realistically can't play for more than an hour you're totally exhausted huh wait were you good i was decent i mean given the amount of hours i played i I definitely wouldn't. Like, let me put it this way. I didn't have DDR talent, but I played so much that I could eventually beat most of the songs on the hardest difficulty. Oh, wait, on the hardest difficulty? I don't think I even ever have played. Like, I think I never lasted more than 10 seconds or whatever. Remember Max 300?
我的意思是，是的，DDR，我在大学时常玩 DDR，是的，你实际上不可能玩超过一个小时，你会完全精疲力竭。哈，等等，你玩得好吗？我还行，考虑到我玩的时长，我肯定不会。这么说吧，我没有 DDR 天赋，但我玩得太多了，以至于最终能在最高难度下通关大多数歌曲。哦，等等，最高难度？我想我甚至从来没玩过。我想我从来没坚持超过 10 秒钟什么的。还记得《Max 300》吗？
No. It was 300 beats per minute. And it was the fastest song. I mean, now they have Faster, but at the time it was the fastest song on the machine, on that version of the machine. And I beat it on hard once. It was sort of like my crowning DDR achievement.
不记得。那是每分钟 300 拍。它是最快的歌。我的意思是，现在有更快的了，但在当时它是机器上、那个版本的机器上最快的歌。我曾在困难模式下通关过一次。那算是我的 DDR 成就巅峰。
But yeah, so I do this virtually. So will you be buying the oculus rift after your demo um i definitely want to buy it yeah it is 700 so that's something to think about um but i thought it was amazing um i played this game where you're in a turret and it was kind of like perfect for the oculus rift because you know you're sitting in this turret like this machine gun turret thing and it can't move it's just stationary um and it's sort of like counter-strike like most shooting games you kind of imagine like like like imagine like those time crisis and these games in the arcade where you have a gun and you're pointing it at the screen and shooting, right?
但是，是的，所以我是在虚拟中做这些。那么你在演示之后会买 Oculus Rift 吗？嗯，我肯定想买，是的。它要 700 美元，所以这是需要考虑的事情。嗯，但我认为它太棒了。嗯，我玩了这个游戏，你在一个炮塔里，它对 Oculus Rift 来说简直完美，因为你知道你坐在那个炮塔里，那个机枪炮塔之类的东西，它不能移动，它是静止的。嗯，它有点像《反恐精英》，大多数射击游戏你都会想象，比如想象一下那些街机里的《化解危机》之类的游戏，你有一把枪，你指着屏幕射击，对吧？
But in this case, it's kind of like Counter-Strike where you look around and it shoots in the middle of the screen wherever that happens to be. And so it's like a little bit of time kind of getting used to that. But once I got used to it, it was awesome. I mean, it was a great experience. I definitely would get one. If it was $300, I wouldn't even think about it. But for $700, I wouldn't think about it. I mean, this is another one of the controversial things,
但在这种情况下，它有点像《反恐精英》，你环顾四周，它会在屏幕中间射击，无论那里是什么。所以需要一点时间来适应。但一旦我适应了，它就太棒了。我的意思是，这是一种很棒的体验。我肯定会买一个。如果它是 300 美元，我甚至都不会考虑。但对于 700 美元，我得考虑一下。我的意思是，这是另一个有争议的事情，
is that you need a beefy PC to play it. Yeah, that's true. I actually just upgraded my computer, not with the intention of VR, but just because it was getting so old it couldn't function anymore and so it's uh just coincidence that i do actually have the right specs oh i do not yeah you have to have a basically you have to have a brand new computer yeah um the one cool so most of the demos seem to be first person but i saw a demo from game developers conference for a third-person VR game where, like,
就是你需要一台强劲的电脑来运行它。是的，那是真的。我实际上刚升级了我的电脑，不是为了 VR，只是因为它太旧了，无法再运行了，所以这纯属巧合，我确实有合适的配置。哦，我没有。是的，你基本上必须有一台全新的电脑。是的，嗯，那个很酷。所以大多数演示似乎都是第一人称的，但我看到了一个来自游戏开发者大会的第三人称 VR 游戏的演示，就像，
you know, you ever played, like, Metal Gear Solid, where you're, like, as you move into different... Is it Metal Gear Solid? Yeah, where, like, you're in a scene, almost like a security camera, and then you move into the next scene, and it kind of jumps, you know, except that you could kind of move the camera around
你知道，你玩过《合金装备》吗？当你移动到不同的……是《合金装备》吗？是的，你在一个场景里，几乎就像一个监控摄像头，然后你移动到下一个场景，它会跳跃，你知道，除了你可以用你的头移动摄像头。
with your head. So your head was tracking the security camera or whatever, but was a fantasy game not a sci-fi game um and basically like you could pure so your guy kind of starts on the left of the screen and then he kind of runs in the room to the right and you kind of have to track over to the right so you can still see him and i thought that was kind of a nifty excuse for like why you're not moving around. Yeah, right, right. That's cool. Yeah, I wonder if, you know, if instead of you sort of,
所以你的头在追踪监控摄像头什么的，但那是一个奇幻游戏，不是科幻游戏。嗯，基本上你可以……所以你的角色从屏幕左侧开始，然后他跑进房间到右侧，你必须追踪到右侧，这样你才能看到他。我觉得这是一个很巧妙的借口，解释为什么你不用四处走动。是的，对，对。那很酷。是的，我想知道，如果不是你那种……
like instead of the camera sort of being first person, as you said, but instead like when you look around, you actually orbit. So it's like if I turn my head to the left, the camera actually just like swivels out. I wonder if that would be disorienting. Yeah, it might be. All right. Well, I think we're on to the news. Yeah, news. So the first news story I have is for all you students or teachers out there, I try and, you know, periodically give you good references for ways to sort of get some kind of free stuff.
不是摄像头那种第一人称视角，正如你所说，而是当你环顾四周时，你实际上是在绕轨道运行。所以就像如果我把头转向左边，摄像头实际上只是向外旋转。我不知道那会不会让人迷失方向。是的，可能会。好了，我想我们该进入新闻环节了。是的，新闻。我有的第一个新闻故事是给你们所有学生或老师的，我尝试定期给你们提供一些好的参考资料，让你们能获得一些免费的东西。
And Amazon has something called AWS Educate. In the past, we've done GitHub. There's a bunch of amazing free stuff you can get through them. We've done a variety of different sources. This one's pretty cool. It gives you $100 a year in free Amazon credit, which you can use to have a server running. That's right, web services credit. So you can use that to have your own server in the cloud running all day for a whole year for free.
亚马逊有一个叫 AWS Educate 的项目。过去我们提过 GitHub。通过他们你可以获得很多很棒的免费资源。我们提过各种不同的来源。这个很酷。它每年给你 100 美元的免费亚马逊额度，你可以用来运行服务器。没错，网络服务额度。所以你可以用它在云端拥有一台全天候运行的服务器，整整一年免费。
If you're an educator, if you're a teacher or something like that, you actually get $200 to share amongst your class. And it's really cool. I mean, you know, $100 actually goes a very long way in AWS. As I said, you can have a server running for a whole year. You could also do like, there's something called Common Crawl, which is a data set um that spans the entire internet so we've talked about this in the past you can use common crawl to like see how many times you know patrick shows up in the internet and just count all the all the patrick yes there's a lot of patrick's they're not me so so i don't even think i rank you didn't search my full name i don't think I rank in Google.
如果你是教育工作者，如果你是老师之类的，你实际上可以获得 200 美元在班级里分享。这真的很酷。我的意思是，你知道，100 美元在 AWS 里其实能用很久。正如我所说，你可以让一台服务器运行整整一年。你也可以做类似的事情，有一个叫 Common Crawl 的东西，它是一个数据集，涵盖了整个互联网。所以我们过去谈过这个，你可以使用 Common Crawl 来查看帕特里克在互联网上出现了多少次，然后数一数所有的帕特里克。是的，有很多帕特里克。他们不是我，所以我甚至不认为我排得上名。你没搜我的全名，我不认为我在谷歌上有排名。
No, you don't have a Twitter account. How can you, how can you rank? Um, do you have a Facebook or no? Does it count unused? And I don't know the login and yeah, sort of. You have a, you have a LinkedIn, right? I applied to Facebook once and I thought it would be a good idea to have a Facebook account. Oh, that seems, that seems like a good idea. Yeah. No, I, so i had one when they came out when you were still had to be at specific universities and i was still in university yeah that's right and then i was like nope i
不，你没有推特账号。你怎么能有排名？嗯，你有脸书吗？还是没有？它算未使用的吗？我不知道登录信息，是的，算是吧。你有领英，对吧？我曾经申请过脸书，我觉得拥有一个脸书账号是个好主意。哦，那听起来是个好主意。是的。不，我……所以当他们刚出来时我有一个，那时你还必须在特定的大学里，而我还在上大学。是的，没错。然后我就想，不，我
actually don't want to relate to these people anymore so i closed it that was before like it was anyone except college students um yeah and i think i'm remembering that correctly anyways and then eventually like i went to recreate correctly anyways and then eventually like i went to recreate it and it turned out like i never it's really hard to actually fully delete your facebook account so it was like dormant or inactive or something and so it reactivated and i never bothered deactivating it again so i but i never go on there i never got it got it i'm an anti-social person you would not show up that often. I one time used Google+. One time.
其实不想再和这些人有联系了，所以我关闭了它。那是在它对除了大学生以外的任何人开放之前。是的，我想我记得没错。无论如何，最终我尝试重新创建它，结果发现我从来……要完全删除你的脸书账号真的很难，所以它处于休眠或不活跃状态什么的，然后它又重新激活了，我再也没去管它。所以我从不去那里，我从来没……明白了，我是一个反社会的人，你不会经常出现。我曾经用过一次 Google+。就一次。
So scanning, you know, for all the Patricks and the whole internet, you have to scan all, you know, I think it's like 200 terabytes of data. And it only costs, I think, like $14. So you can see how, like, you have incredible computational resources at your disposal for free if you get this. So it's called AWS Educate. If you're a student or a teacher, definitely go here, get your free credit, and check it out.
所以扫描整个互联网上的所有帕特里克，你必须扫描所有，你知道，我想大约是 200 TB 的数据。而且它只花费了大约 14 美元。所以你可以看到，如果你得到这个，你就有令人难以置信的免费计算资源供你使用。所以它叫 AWS Educate。如果你是学生或老师，一定要去看看，领取你的免费额度。
It's awesome. Awesome. MAME went open source, and the entire Internet said, wait, wasn't it already open source? Yeah, exactly. But I think this is an interesting story, and I put it in here, I guess partly because of that. And I know, Jason, you may have more context for this,
这太棒了。太棒了。MAME 开源了，整个互联网都在说，等等，它不是已经开源了吗？是的，完全正确。但我认为这是一个有趣的故事，我把它放进来，我想部分原因就是因为这个。我知道，杰森，你可能对此有更多的背景信息，
but when you get a bunch of people together and write code, there's actually a lot of legal implications, whether you mean for there to be or not, and who owns the code, who has a right to the code and these kinds of things are always very confusing and tricky and the one i always remember isn't really related to code i'm trying to remember now i guess the guy who helped design the stormtrooper helmet for the original star wars like it was unclear the manner the contract and manner under which he got paid whether he retained any licensing to the or any of the rights to stormtrooper helmets and so like he and lucas
但当你把一群人聚在一起写代码时，实际上有很多法律含义，无论你是否有意为之，谁拥有代码，谁有权使用代码，这些事情总是非常令人困惑和棘手。我一直记得的一件事其实与代码无关，我现在试着回忆一下，我想那个帮助设计《星球大战》原版冲锋队头盔的人，合同方式和支付方式很不明确，他不确定是否保留了冲锋队头盔的任何许可或权利，所以他和卢卡斯
film i guess or whoever owns the rights to star wars uh like went back and forth with several lawsuits because he would make products or molds based off of those things that he made and claimed he had ownership to be able to do that, and they said he didn't. It just reminds me how complicated. Basically, if someone does work, whether you pay them or not for you, and produces something,
影业，或者无论谁拥有《星球大战》的权利，来回进行了几次诉讼，因为他会根据他制作的那些东西制作产品或模具，并声称他拥有这样做的所有权，而他们说他没有。这让我想起它是多么复杂。基本上，如果有人为你工作，无论你是否付钱给他们，并生产了东西，
who owns the thing, any copies of the thing, the likeness of the thing? If you don't nail it down, it can get really confusing. That is sort of related, I think, to what happened in Maine, is that people developed under different assumptions different licenses and then to change it you basically have to go back and get all of them to agree to it that's right and there there's there's some parts of maim i think it's actually the software scaler if i remember correctly so i'm a maim developer i've worked on it for a while actually just a short tangent i got a nasty gram from paypal today and they said that basically it was from their
谁拥有这个东西，这个东西的任何副本，这个东西的肖像权？如果你不把它落实清楚，它会变得非常令人困惑。我认为这与 MAME 发生的事情有关，人们在不同的假设和不同的许可下开发，然后要改变它，你基本上必须回去让所有人都同意。没错，而且 MAME 有一些部分，我想如果我没记错的话，实际上是软件缩放器。所以我是一个 MAME 开发者，我工作了一段时间。其实跑个题，我今天收到了一封来自 PayPal 的措辞严厉的邮件，他们说基本上是来自他们的
brand integrity department and uh they so i have a donate page on meme hub which is a fork of name that i maintain and uh meme hub comes with a fork of Mame that I maintain. And Mame Hub comes with a bunch of servers and infrastructure and everything. And so the donation is just kind of keep the lights on. I don't actively work on it anymore, but there's still a community and they maintain themselves financially through the donations. So PayPal basically said, look, anything having to do with emulators hurts our brand. They don't want to be associated with it. And so they put my account in this sort of restricted mode where I couldn't do anything until I removed the donate button from my website.
品牌诚信部门。嗯，我在 Mame Hub 上有一个捐赠页面，这是我维护的一个 Mame 分支。Mame Hub 附带了一堆服务器和基础设施等等。所以捐赠只是为了维持运营。我不再积极参与开发了，但仍然有一个社区，他们通过捐赠在经济上维持自己。所以 PayPal 基本上说，看，任何与模拟器有关的东西都会损害我们的品牌。他们不想与之关联。所以他们把我的账户置于这种受限模式，直到我从网站上删除捐赠按钮，否则我什么也做不了。
So, like, in the email, they said, it's not illegal, like, what you're doing. We don't think it's illegal or anything. We just don't want to be associated with it um but is this a recent change i just recently figured out about you well i mean maim maim hub is reasonably popular i wouldn't say it's hugely popular but um you know it's been going on maim hub's been going on for about six years and i've had the donate button almost the entire time and uh you know i just got this nasty gram today and it's not like the volume of donations has increased or anything so um weird anyway so um so the software scaler in maim uh is gpl licensed the person who wrote it wanted to be gpl licensed and so i think even now today
所以，在邮件里，他们说，你做的事情并不违法。我们不认为它是非法的或什么的。我们只是不想与之关联。嗯，这是一个最近的变化吗？我刚发现关于你的事。嗯，我的意思是 Mame Hub 相当受欢迎，我不会说它非常受欢迎，但嗯，你知道，它已经运行了大约六年，我几乎一直都有捐赠按钮。嗯，你知道，我今天刚收到这封严厉的邮件，并不是捐赠量增加了什么的。所以，嗯，奇怪。无论如何，所以，MAME 中的软件缩放器是 GPL 许可的。写它的人希望它是 GPL 许可的，所以我认为即使是现在，今天
that is still under a gpl license but everything else in maim has been moved to bsd and as patrick said it literally came down to talking to every single contributor and getting them all to agree to change a license and so it was free to download before but there were restrictions upon like using it in commercial works and that's right it was not it was not to download before, but there were restrictions upon using it in commercial works. That's right. It was not allowed to be used in commercial works. And that's why, kind of a funny story, if you have a PS1, actually or any PS, I guess, there was a PS1 game called Atari Arcade Classics.
它仍然在 GPL 许可下，但 MAME 中的其他一切都已迁移到 BSD。正如帕特里克所说，这实际上归结为与每一位贡献者交谈并让他们都同意更改许可。所以它以前可以免费下载，但对在商业作品中使用它有限制。没错，它以前不允许在商业作品中使用。这就是为什么，一个有趣的故事，如果你有 PS1，或者任何 PS，我想，有一个叫《Atari Arcade Classics》的 PS1 游戏。
And if you plug a keyboard into your playstation and hit tab you'll actually bring up the maim debug menu so it was like you know blatantly obvious that they were just forked maiming they just built maim for the for the playstation um and and it turns out they did they worked a special license out with the maim team and uh and so a lot of people felt as if um having that license uh forced sony to um pay us like pay maim and and set up an agreement to to have a commercial you know fork of maim but the reality is like MAME is a pretty complicated beast. And so to do something like compile MAME for the
如果你把键盘插到你的 PlayStation 上并按下 Tab 键，你实际上会调出 MAME 调试菜单。所以就像，你知道，显而易见，他们只是分叉了 MAME。他们只是为 PlayStation 构建了 MAME。而且事实证明，他们确实做到了，他们与 MAME 团队制定了一个特殊的许可协议。所以很多人觉得，拥有那个许可迫使索尼向我们支付费用，向 MAME 支付费用，并建立了一个协议来拥有一个商业的 MAME 分支。但现实是，MAME 是一个相当复杂的野兽。所以要做像为 PlayStation 编译 MAME 这样的事情，你需要大量的专业知识、指导和咨询。所以使许可在商业上兼容并不意味着该项目将不再获得资助。所以是的。所以你现在可以随心所欲地使用 MAME，无论是商业用途还是其他用途，这是一件很酷的事情。
PlayStation, you need a ton of expertise and guidance and consulting. And so making the license commercially compatible doesn't mean that the project won't get funded anymore. So yeah. So you can do whatever you want with maim now commercially or otherwise and that's that's a cool thing
许可很令人困惑，这就是为什么律师赚很多钱。没错，完全正确。这就是为什么，如果你与许可有任何关系，你绝对应该让律师参与进来。我认为有，被称为……让律师参与进来。我认为有，那叫什么，公益服务，比如免费工作。我想有，我以前见过律师愿意帮助处理这类开源事物以及围绕它们的问题。是的。我可能是编造的，但我从未尝试寻求他们的服务，我不知道他们是否是你想要寻求服务的人，
licenses confusing this is why lawyers make a lot of money that's right exactly and this is why uh you should definitely if you have anything to do with licensing you should definitely have a lawyer involved and i think there are which are called pro have a lawyer involved. And I think there are, what is it called, pro bono, like working for free. I think there are, I've seen stuff before from lawyers willing to, you know, help out with these kinds of open source things and questions around them. Yep. I may be making that up, but I've never tried to seek their services, and I don't know if those are people who you'd want their services or not,
但我认为我以前见过，所以这总是值得考虑的。我想谈谈，这可能现在有点旧了，但我仍然对此感到非常兴奋。我实际上收听并观看了这个。我觉得如果它还没有成为历史性事件，那它也将是历史性的，那就是 AlphaGo 与李世石进行的围棋比赛。大多数人都同意，李世石在过去十年左右一直是统治级的，如果不是世界冠军的话，并将作为一位著名的围棋选手载入史册。所以 AlphaGo 与他比赛是一件大事。他们正在玩
but I think I've seen it before, so it's always something to consider as well. I would like to talk a little bit about, this is probably a little old by now, but I'm still really excited about it. And I actually tuned in and watched this. I feel like it is going to be momentous if it isn't already, which was AlphaGo playing the game of go against lee sadal uh which most people agree has been dominant if not the world champion for like about a decade and will go down as like a famous go player um and so alpha go playing him was a big deal they were playing
为了让人们了解背景，AlphaGo 是一个机器学习人工智能，它正在与李世石进行围棋比赛，李世石是一个人类，可以说是世界上顶尖的围棋选手之一。一台计算机能够击败一个人，是四比一吗？是的，没错。所以他们有趣的是，我不知道，我本想查一下，但我不知道是围棋规则还是这里为了避免任何滑稽行为，基本上他们说我们将进行五局三胜制，但他们说即使一个人或计算机达到了三局，他们也会打满五局。所以 AlphaGo 连赢了前三局，
just so people know the context so alpha go is a machine learning an ai that was playing go against lee sadal who's a human being who was arguably the one of the world uh one of the top world uh go players and a computer was able to beat a person uh was it four games to one yep that's right so they interestingly i don't know i meant to look this up but i don't know if it's the rules of go or specifically here to avoid any uh funny business that basically they said we'll play five games is best of five so three to win um but they said even if a person or the computer reaches three games, they'll play all five regardless. And so AlphaGo won the first three in a row,
锁定了整个比赛的胜利，奖金是一百万美元，我想是由拥有 DeepMind 的谷歌提供的，DeepMind 编写了 AlphaGo 程序。但他们把一百万美元捐给了慈善机构，但如果李世石赢了，他会赢得一百万美元。但他们赢了前三局，然后李世石赢了第四局，谷歌赢了，AlphaGo 赢了第五局。对。
securing its victory for the entire thing with a million dollars on the line, which I think was put up by Google, who owns DeepMind, who wrote the AlphaGo program. But they donated a million dollars to charity, but Lee Sedol would have won a million dollars if he had won. But they won the first three, then Lee Sedol won the fourth one, and Google won AlphaGo, won the fifth one. Right.
这里有趣的事情是，嗯，实际上有很多有趣的事实。所以一个是，我在线收看了。所以它在韩国是现场直播，而在我们西海岸是深夜，大约晚上 8 点、9 点。围棋比赛显然持续很长时间，我绝对一直熬到凌晨 2 点。是的，是的。嗯，他们有的评论，你知道，在美国围棋不是很流行，但在其他地方，嗯，在亚洲，我想亚洲的几个国家，中国、韩国，我想日本也很流行，真的很流行。所以他们实际上有职业选手在下围棋，所以他们有评论员在那里，他们周围有一个新闻室，他们有英语评论，
And the interesting thing here, well, there's actually many interesting facts. So one is that I tuned in live. So it was live in Korea, which here on the West Coast was late late in the evening like 8 p.m 9 p.m go games last a pretty long time apparently i was definitely up till 2 a.m yeah yeah um the commentary they had i you know they did in america go isn't very big but everywhere else well in asia i guess several countries in asia china korea and i think japan is pretty big like really big um and so they're actually paid professionals playing uh go and so they had commentators there they had like a press room around it and they had commentary in english
我在西海岸看了，我觉得现场观看真是太棒了，尽管它看起来有点奇怪，看起来有点书呆子气，但我感觉我一直读到卡斯帕罗夫和深蓝，我觉得这又发生了，我想说我现场看了。是的，这太神奇了。嗯，有几点需要注意。所以，第一，李世石，他给出了很多关于比赛和所有事情的评论。你提到的几点，我觉得很迷人，当你思考它时很有道理，那就是人类，他们一次追求一个主动权。所以一个人可能会专注于棋盘的一个区域，并且有一种协议，我的意思是，不是官方的，但你知道，如果我在左下角放一颗棋子，并且在棋盘的左下角发生了一些战斗，那会吸引我对手的注意，他会把棋子放在那里，然后我们会在棋盘的左下角进行一场小战斗。但当你与 AlphaGo 对战时，它并不真正关心上一步发生了什么。它只是观察棋盘的当前状态，并说，我现在要做什么？然后当轮到它时，它再次进行那个过程。它重新开始，观察棋盘的当前状态，并说，我现在应该做什么？所以它可能在棋盘的两端同时进行两场战斗，
that i watched on the west coast and i i thought it was just awesome to like watch it live even though it was kind of weird like seemed kind of nerdy but i feel like i've always read about kasparov and deep blue and i felt like this was happening again and i wanted to like say i watched it live yeah it was amazing um just a few like uh um things to note so so one so lisa at all he gave a lot of commentary about um you know the games and everything. And a few things you mentioned, which I thought were fascinating and make sense when you think about it, is humans, they pursue one initiative at a time. So a human might concentrate on one area of the board, and there's sort of this agreement like i mean not not officially but you know if i place a stone on the bottom left and there's some some some battle going on in
它只是在两者之间交替。这就是让李世石感到难以置信的困难的事情，你知道，当那种社会契约被打破时，现在他必须不断地换挡。他实际上，我不记得他确切说了什么，但大意是，我真的不喜欢玩这些游戏。我没看到那个评论。哦，是的，是的，他说了一些类似的话，因为这个原因以及它在精神上如此令人疲惫的事实，我真的不喜欢玩这些游戏。
the bottom left of the board that's going to draw the attention of my opponent and he's going to place a stone there and then we're going to have a little battle on the bottom left of the board. But when you're playing against AlphaGo, it doesn't really care about what happened last move. It just it looks at the current state of the board and says, what am I going to do now? And and then when it when it's its turn again, it does that process again. It starts over, it looks at the current state of the board, and says, like, what should I do now? And so it might have two battles going simultaneously on different ends of the board,
有趣。是的，这超级有趣。我想我们在之前的某个播客中谈论过 AlphaGo 的架构，当时它刚宣布时。但是，是的，我的意思是，其中一件事是它这样做，比如，作为对人类的利用，知道人类会有困难，这会很有趣。我不认为他们那样做了。不，我也不这么认为。但是，是的，我的意思是人们说它的走法通常非常像人类，如果这有意义的话。
and it just alternates between the two. And that was something that gave Lee Sedol incredible difficulty was that, you know, when that sort of social contract was broken now he has to sort of constantly keep shifting gears and he was actually i don't remember exactly what he said but it was something to the effect of i really didn't enjoy playing these games i didn't see that comment oh yeah yeah he said something like i really didn't enjoy playing these games because of this and the fact that it was just so mentally straining.
我对围棋了解不够，无法理解他们所说的，但我猜它看起来像是在下人类能下的棋。但是，是的，比如在棋盘的一边和另一边下棋，因为它在那里看到了更多的机会。这本身并不是一件不礼貌的事情，但是的，这非常有挑战性，因为作为人类，你并没有预料到它会发生。没错，没错。我能理解。超级超级迷人。嗯，如果你还没有，你知道，虽然它是现场直播的，但你仍然可以去观看。我想它在 YouTube 上。一定要去看看。所以，我的意思是，连续看六个小时很无聊，所以不要那样做。即使你已经知道会发生什么，因为即使你看了 15 分钟的游戏总结，他们也不会把整场比赛打完，这更像是围棋策略评论。他们还没做的是，或者我还没看到的是，嗯，我当时想看，但我想它会剧透一点，或者也许你不能把它展示给李世石，但如果 AlphaGo 对它认为自己做得如何有一个评估，对吧？一个非常实际的数字，而不是像人类那样只有一个模糊的想法。我会很好奇看到一个仪表，你知道，AlphaGo 显示它目前认为自己获胜的概率是多少。
Interesting. Yeah, it's super interesting. I think we talked about the architecture of AlphaGo a little bit in a previous podcast at some point when it was first kind of announced. But, yeah, I mean, one of the things is it doing that, like, as an exploit to humans right knowing that humans would have trouble would be interesting i don't think they did that no i don't think so either but yeah i mean people were saying that its moves were often very human-like if that makes sense i
哦，看看它是如何随时间变化的。他们确实为它输掉的那一场比赛做了。他们实际上展示了李世石做出的某个动作。或者不，抱歉。它做出了某个动作，李世石做出了……或者不，抱歉，有一个错误，对吧？是的，没错，它认为这是一个好动作，实际上在几步之后，最终它意识到这不是一个好动作，但已经太晚了。所以这对我来说会很有趣。然后我想有两件事我想说。第一，首先 AlphaGo 引用了杰森，
don't know enough about go to be able to kind of understand what they're saying but i guess it seemed like it was playing music humans could play but yeah like playing one side of the board and another because it sees more opportunity there like it isn't a impolite thing to do per se but yeah it's very challenging because you're kind of not expecting it to happen as a human that's right that's right i could see that super super super fascinating um if you haven't uh you know although it was streamed live you know you can still go and watch it um i think it's on youtube um definitely check it out so i mean it's it's boring to watch it for six hours straight so don't do that and even though you already know what's gonna happen because even if you watch the 15 minute like summary of a game they don't play
我们 Programming Throwdown 的出色联合主持人。所以你在这里帮助创造了历史。是的，关于这个的简短故事是，DeepMind 深度学习论文始于一篇在转向围棋之前玩雅达利的论文。他们使用雅达利来验证他们的算法。而雅达利论文实际上引用了一篇拥有我发明的名为 HyperNEAT 算法的论文。所以是的，这是进入学术界的一件很酷的事情，成为其中的一部分。
out the whole game and it's more of like a go strategy commentary what they haven't done yet or i haven't seen is um and what i wanted to watch when it was happening but i guess it would have spoiled it a little uh or maybe you couldn't have shown it to like lisa doll for instance but would have been so alpha go has an assessment of how it thinks it's doing right a very actual number as opposed to a human who just has a vague idea, I guess. And I would have been curious to see, like, a meter, you know, AlphaGo showing what it currently believes its probability of winning is.
我敢说这是唯一酷的事情吗？是的，可能吧。你知道，它是，是的。所以我的意思是，他们过去 10 年做了令人难以置信的工作。而且很多人实际上一直在做神经网络工作。实际上，DeepMind 的负责人之一大卫·西尔弗，在 2003 年左右写了一个叫 NeuroGo 的东西，这是一个下围棋的神经网络。
Oh, and see how that changes over time. They did do that for the one game it lost. They actually showed there's a certain move that LisaDahl made. Or no, sorry. It made certain move that lisa doll made um or no sorry there's a mistake right yeah that's right and it and it thought it was a good move for actually several moves later and then eventually it realized that it wasn't a good move but it was too late right so that would be interesting for me to see uh And then I guess there's two things I want to say. One is first that AlphaGo cited Jason,
所以他很长一段时间以来一直对下围棋的神经网络感兴趣。有趣。是的。但我发现迷人的第二件事，除了祝贺杰森击败世界冠军，我想知道你的程序是否能击败它。不，我开玩笑的。
our wonderful co-host here on Programming Throwdown. So you helped make history here. Yeah, short story about that is the DeepMind deep learning paper started with a paper that played Atari before they moved on to Go. And they used Atari to kind of prove out their algorithm. And the Atari paper actually references a paper that has an algorithm called Hyperneet that I invented. So yeah, so this is one of the cool things about going into academia is kind of being a part of that.
不，绝对不能。好的。但有趣的是进步的速度。所以就像杰森说的，我们作为计算机人、程序员，无论什么，已经研究围棋有一段时间了。杰森尝试过。这家伙尝试过。
Dare I say the only cool thing? Yeah, probably. You know, it's, yeah. So I mean, it's, I mean, they've done just an incredible amount of work over the past 10 years. And a lot of those people actually have been doing neural network work. Actually, David Silver, who's one of the heads of DeepMind, wrote a thing called NeuroGo, which is a neural network that plays Go back in around 2003.
而 AlphaGo 之前击败了欧洲冠军，我想那是我们之前谈过的一篇新闻文章。但在对那场比赛的分析中，所以那个人，我猜，排名大约是一千，是我看到的，而李世石目前排名，我想他们说是第二或第三。他们说对那场比赛的分析，他们确实看到了它下棋方式的很多缺陷。而在那之后到秋天，现在这里，我猜是冬末初春，还没到春天，
And so he's been interested in neural networks that play Go for a very long time. Interesting. Yeah. But one of the things that I find fascinating, the second thing, aside from the congratulations to Jason and beating the world champion, which I want to know if your program could beat it. No, I'm just kidding.
但当他玩的时候，它进步了这么多，以至于它从排名可能比一千稍微高一点，一直到能够击败世界冠军，一个世界冠军级别的人。那种加速率，人类永远不可能在那个时间段内玩足够多的游戏或学到足够多的东西，我不认为，为了能够进步得那么快。没错，没错。但你知道，我的意思是，哦，抱歉，你继续。哦，我只是想说，他们拥有令人难以置信的资源，一旦他们能让计算机朝着正确的方向发展，现在它相当于成千上万的人类年的学习。
No, absolutely not. Okay. But the interesting thing is the rate of progress. So like Jason was saying, we've been working on Go for a while as computer people, programmers, whatever. Jason took a stab at it. This guy's taking a stab at it.
是的。而且你知道，迷人的是，即使在当时，你知道，我猜脸书也宣布它正在研究围棋，它正在击败业余爱好者，他们想到了伟大的事情。
And AlphaGo previously had beaten the European champion, which I think was a news article we talked about before. But in analysis of that game, so that guy, I guess, is approximately ranked about a thousand um is what i've seen and lisa doll is ranked currently i think they were saying like number two or three currently um and they were saying like analysis of that game they really saw a lot of flaws in the way it played um and in between there and the fall and now here it was i guess late winter early not spring yet
谷歌出来说，嘿，我们击败了欧洲冠军。然后现在，你知道，基本上你拥有了等同于……我猜在某些方面，实际上他们做了很多事情来……关于加里·卡斯帕罗夫对阵深蓝有很多争议，我认为谷歌试图做很多事情
but um when he played that improved so much that it went from being ranked you know maybe slightly above a thousand to all the way about able to beat the world champion for a world champion caliber person and that rate of acceleration a human could never ever play enough games or learn enough in that time period i don't think um in order to be able to progress that quickly that's right that's right but you know i mean oh sorry go ahead oh i was just going to say it's it's it's they have an incredible amount of resources and and once they can get the computer kind of in the right direction now it's the equivalent of thousands and thousands of human years of, of,
来确保如果他们赢了就不会有争议，他们最终做到了。是的，所以我认为，你知道，我想在五年、十年、二十年后，我们是否会记得现场观看了那些比赛。是的，我的意思是，我希望如此，我的意思是这确实是一个历史性的时刻。很多人在说一些不真实的难以置信的事情，比如我们现在会有终结者，我看到了那些角落里的强壮家伙，这些都不是真的，但这仍然很酷。哦，这是一个有趣的观点，我们可以谈谈那个，也许我们应该……我们有过关于人工智能的剧集吗？我想我们有一集关于机器学习的。是的，我们应该做一集人工智能，这听起来是个好主意。我相信我能找到人，比如
of learning. Yep. And you know, fascinating too is like, even at the time, you know, I guess Facebook had announced also that it was working on go, that it was beating amateurs and they thought about great things.
什么是强人工智能，以及为什么 AlphaGo 将无法控制波士顿动力机器人。我们应该……我向你们保证，我们会做一集人工智能，我会找个很酷的人来参加节目。哦，就是这样。哦，你知道人们，所以我猜这可能会发生。是的，我们会做的，我们会做的。好的，非常棒。但是的，我希望我们会回顾这一点，你知道，记住，哦，我记得那天。没错，无论如何，是的，它是……这太神奇了。是的，这是一个非常超前的酷炫时刻。节目推荐书，我的节目推荐书是《编程大师》。所以这本书是……对编程语言发明者的采访合集，
Google came out like saying, Hey, we beat the European champion. And then now like, you know, basically you have the equivalent i guess in some ways actually they did a lot of things to be there's a lot of controversy around gary casper versus deep blue um and i think google tried to do a lot of stuff
以及其他一些编程先驱。它实际上是由蒂姆推荐的，我不打算说你的姓氏，但蒂姆，谢谢你的推荐。是的，它看起来是一本非凡的书。它显然在设计上非常轶事化。所以，嗯，你知道，如果你想学习 C++ 或类似的东西，不要拿起这本书。它不是一个好的
to make sure there wouldn't be controversy if they won which they eventually did um yeah and so i think you know i wonder in five years 10 years 20 years if we'll remember having watched those games live yeah i mean i hope so i mean it is truly a historic moment a lot of people are saying incredulous things that aren't true like we're gonna have terminator now i saw those you know strong guys around the corner none of these things are true but it's still cool oh that's an interesting point we could talk about that maybe we should have have we had an episode about artificial intelligence i think we have one about machine learning yeah we should do an ai episode that sounds like a good idea i'm sure i could find someone like the difference between
参考资料，但是，嗯，我，它是一本迷人的读物。所以我强烈推荐它。我的书是约翰·斯卡尔齐的《红衫》，他在一次采访中说，他写的科幻小说你奶奶可能喜欢读。我不知道我奶奶是否会关心读这本书，但《红衫》，如果你是《星际迷航》的粉丝，而我是一个相当糟糕的
like what is strong ai and uh yeah like why alpha go won't be able to control a boston dynamics robot um we should we'll do i promise you guys out there we'll do an ai episode and i'll find somebody cool to come on the show oh that's it oh you know people though so i guess that could happen yeah we'll do it we'll do it all right very awesome but yeah i hope we'll look back on this and you know remember oh i remember the day that's right anyways yeah it's uh it is amazing yeah it's a hugely forward time for cool book of the show book of the show my book the show is masterminds of programming and so this book is um a collection of sort of interviews with programming language inventors
《星际迷航》粉丝，意思是并不是真正的粉丝，我只是从来没有真正进入过它。是的。我越想它，我，因为我，我碰巧不知怎么想到了我不知道任何关于……的事实。
and other people who are sort of pioneers in programming it's actually recommended by Tim I'm not going to say your last name but Tim thank you for the recommendation and yeah it looks like a phenomenal book. It's obviously very anecdotal by, by design. So, um, you know, don't pick up this book if you're trying to learn C++ or something like that. It's not a good
以及其他编程领域的先驱们。这本书其实是Tim推荐的，我就不念你的姓了，但Tim，谢谢你的推荐，它看起来确实是一本了不起的书。显然，它在设计上就是非常轶事化的。所以，嗯，如果你是想学习C++之类的东西，就别选这本书了。它不是一本好的
reference, but, uh, I, it's a, it's a fascinating, uh, uh, fascinating read. And so highly recommend it my book is Red Shirts by John Scalzi who in an interview I guess said he writes science fiction your grandma might like to read I don't know that my grandmother would care to read this book but Red Shirts if you are a Star Trek fan which I'm a pretty bad
参考书，但是，呃，我，它是一本，一本引人入胜的读物。所以我强烈推荐它。我的书是约翰·斯卡尔齐（John Scalzi）的《红衫》（Red Shirts），他在一次采访中说他写的科幻小说是你奶奶可能会喜欢读的。我不知道我奶奶会不会想读这本书，但《红衫》，如果你是《星际迷航》的粉丝，虽然我是一个很糟糕的
Star Trek fan meaning not really a Star Trek fan I don't not like I've just never really gotten into it. Yeah. The more I thought about it, I, cause I, I happened to somehow came up the fact that I don't know anything about
《星际迷航》粉丝，意思是其实算不上《星际迷航》粉丝，我并不是不喜欢，只是从来没真正深入了解过。是的。我越想越觉得，因为我，我碰巧不知怎么就提到了我对它一无所知的事实
Star Trek. And I realized I don't really know anything about Star Trek. I still haven't seen all the Star Wars movies when it comes to like nerd culture. I actually rank pretty poorly. The only thing I really have going for me is i'm a gamer babylon 5 i've seen like one episode oh um what is the other one oh battlestar galactica i've heard of it but that's oh oh jason i know this is kind of shameful kind of it was really
星际迷航。我意识到我对星际迷航其实一无所知。说到书呆子文化，我甚至还没看完所有的《星球大战》电影。我的排名其实很低。我唯一拿得出手的就是我是一个游戏玩家，《巴比伦5号》我只看过一集，哦，还有那个什么来着，哦，《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》，我听说过，但那是……哦，杰森，我知道这有点丢人，真的有点……
like a moment of self-actualization when i realized that as far as from a cultural perspective the only nerd thing i've going for me is is is gaming no you have a lot of nerd things dude you were like a really good chess player for a while yeah i'm all i'm roping all that together. Yeah, yeah. So definitely the programming and the gaming, like board games, video games, card games. Like that I'm just super into. But yeah, movies, TV shows, you know, dress, like apparel and all of that. I still have to catch on to all that. Wait, you are nerdy with apparel or not?
就像是一个自我实现的时刻，我意识到从文化角度来看，我唯一拿得出的书呆子爱好就是游戏。不，你有很多书呆子爱好，伙计。你有一段时间是个很厉害的国际象棋选手。是的，我把这些都归在一起了。是的，没错。所以编程和游戏绝对是，比如棋盘游戏、电子游戏、卡牌游戏。这些我超级喜欢。但电影、电视剧，你知道，还有穿搭，服装之类的。我还需要补补课。等等，你在服装方面也是个书呆子吗？
Wait, I'm not sure what you mean. So you dress well or just poorly because dressing poorly is a nerdy thing to do uh that's true what i i guess what i want like all right red shirts so those are reference to star trek and uh they kind of what happened what would happen if people who were in a non-franchise infringing version of Star Trek realized that some of the stuff happening was ridiculous? I think I stole that line from the book or a very similar line. And kind of like, you know, why is it that the, you know, navigator for the entire spaceship goes down to the surface of the planet to investigate a murder like why right that doesn't make sense and then also like people who go down to the
等等，我不确定你是什么意思。你是说你穿得好还是穿得差？因为穿得差也是书呆子的一种表现。呃，那倒是真的。我想说的是……好吧，红衫军，那是对《星际迷航》的致敬。如果那些身处非侵权版《星际迷航》里的人意识到发生的一些事情很荒谬，会怎样？我想我从书里偷了这个梗，或者类似的梗。就像，为什么整艘飞船的领航员要下到行星表面去调查谋杀案？为什么？这说不通。还有，那些下到
planet die like really really often uh and if you're wearing a red shirt you're almost guaranteed to get killed oh right because they gave the extra the red shirt right well because the security team i think is the people wearing the red shirts and so they're just kind of like yeah if you didn't have a name you were gonna die and yeah anyway so there's all this you know like cheesy plot points and what happens if the people kind of picked up that like wait a second uh this doesn't seem statistically likely um so it's a really fun read it's it's it's a funny book uh i listen to it on audible because i have a long commute i always do i always say i read the book but i really listen to it um and this is read by recorded by will wheaton um which oh nice was who was on star trek that's
行星上的人死得非常非常频繁。如果你穿着红衫，你几乎注定会被杀。哦，对了，因为他们把红衫给了龙套，对吧？嗯，因为保安队我想就是穿红衫的人，所以他们就像是，是的，如果你没有名字，你就会死。是的，总之，所有这些俗气的剧情点，如果人们发现了这一点，比如“等一下，这在统计学上看起来不太可能”，会发生什么？所以这是一本非常有趣的书，它很搞笑。我在Audible上听的，因为我通勤时间很长。我总是这么说，我总是说我读了这本书，但其实我是听的。这本书是由威尔·惠顿录制的，哦，不错，他以前演过《星际迷航》，那是
right and so wesley crusher was that's right wesley crusher and so it's kind of even more interesting to hear him voicing this where it's not actually star trek right because it can't be because they didn't have the license and so i and he's also just a funny person to listen to so it was a really good fit for him to read this book um and so i like that so even if i had read the book i might have still listened to it just to hear him do the like emoting of the ridiculousness of some of this stuff um yeah yeah will wheaton by the way he has an amazing uh um channel on youtube where he covers board games and video games i think it's called tabletop yeah it's called tabletop so um will whedon's uh is is awesome so yeah that sounds like an amazing audiobook and he also records ready player one which is another book i've recommended and people have written
对的，卫斯理·克拉舍就是他。没错，卫斯理·克拉舍。所以听到他为这个角色配音更有趣，因为这实际上不是《星际迷航》，对吧？因为它不能是，因为他们没有版权。而且他本人也是个很有趣的人，所以由他来读这本书非常合适。所以我喜欢这一点，即使我读过这本书，我可能还是会听一遍，就为了听他演绎其中一些荒谬的情节。是的，顺便说一下，威尔·惠顿在YouTube上有一个很棒的频道，他会介绍棋盘游戏和电子游戏，我想叫《Tabletop》。是的，叫《Tabletop》。所以威尔·惠顿真的很棒。听起来那是一本很棒的有声书。他还录制了《头号玩家》，这也是我推荐过的一本书，人们写信
in and been like that is an amazing book um yep so i like and that has virtual reality in it so uh yeah ready player one is it was amazing i read it based on your recommendation and i absolutely did you did you read it or you listened to it i read it okay okay listening to it is even i have a long i have a long commute but it is a shuttle i'm on a shuttle and so uh you don't have headphones so i read anyways well others if you have long commutes well if if given the choice I would draw the read but if I have a long drive then I would obviously
来说那是一本很棒的书。是的，我喜欢，而且里面有虚拟现实的内容。所以，是的，《头号玩家》太棒了。我是根据你的推荐读的，我绝对……你读了还是听了？我读了。好吧，好吧，听的话甚至……我的通勤时间很长，但我坐的是班车，所以没有耳机，所以我读了。总之，如果其他人有很长的通勤时间……好吧，如果可以选择，我会选择读，但如果我要开车，那我显然会……
okay fair enough because you could do other stuff you can be on your laptop yeah okay or read okay fair enough but you're missing out anyways if others of you audible is a sponsor of our podcast and if you would like to have a free one month trial
好吧，有道理，因为你可以做别的事，你可以在笔记本电脑上工作。是的，好吧，或者阅读。好吧，有道理，但你错过了。总之，如果其他人……Audible是我们播客的赞助商，如果你想要一个月的免费试用，
which means you can get a credit which is good for a book you can go to www.audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown um and they'll get you set up and then we get a little bit of money to help support the show uh and you can cancel it as soon as you pick out your book uh and then they don't i think you require a credit card but once you cancel it as soon as you pick out your book. And then they don't... I think you require a credit card, but once you cancel it, they won't charge your card. And if you want to keep it going, I actually pay out of my pocket for a monthly subscription, one book a month.
这意味着你可以获得一个积分，可以用来换一本书。你可以去 www.audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，他们会帮你设置好，然后我们会得到一点钱来支持这个节目。你选好书后就可以立即取消订阅。我想他们需要信用卡，但一旦你选好书并取消，他们就不会扣你的钱。如果你想继续，我其实是自掏腰包订阅的，一个月一本书。
And then they run a lot of sales and stuff. And so this is just a PSA for all the people out there with long commutes, because I really... This does help me a lot. The book I'm listening to now, which I'll probably recommend next show, I'm really into. It actually sounds stupid,
而且他们经常搞促销之类的。所以这只是给所有通勤时间长的人的一个公益广告，因为这对我帮助真的很大。我现在正在听的那本书，我可能会在下期节目推荐，我真的很喜欢。听起来其实很蠢，
but I want to get in my car so I can listen to it. When someone else rides with me, I have to take my kids to the sitters. I'm like, oh, I can't listen to my book. It really does help. They run a lot of good sales and stuff, so you can get even more than your one book by buying other books for discounted prices um nice and so
但我很想上车，这样我就可以听它了。当别人跟我一起坐车时，我得送孩子去保姆那，我就想，哦，我不能听我的书了。它真的很有帮助。他们经常搞很多好的促销活动，所以你可以通过购买其他打折书籍获得比你那一本书更多的内容。不错，所以
for people like me who would rather read the book um if you go to programmingthrowdown.com we have links to our book of the show and there's special links if you use our links then amazon gives us a little kickback and we we also put that towards bandwidth and other infrastructure stuff. And to finish out shilling for ways you can support the show, which just listening to it and downloading is also a good way to support the show, telling your friends about it on that Facebook thing that I'm not on.
对于像我这样宁愿读书的人，如果你去 programmingthrowdown.com，我们有节目推荐书籍的链接，还有特殊的链接。如果你使用我们的链接，亚马逊会给我们一点回扣，我们也会把这些钱用于带宽和其他基础设施建设。为了结束这些支持节目的方式，仅仅是收听和下载也是支持节目的好方法，在那个我没用的Facebook上告诉你的朋友。
Or I don't know if anyone's on Google Plus anymore. Like you could do it on Google Plus. I still see people adding me on Google Plus, so I know you guys are out there still using Google Plus. Sorry if I don't ever respond because I never check it. But you can also support us on Patreon.
或者我不知道还有没有人用Google Plus。你可以去Google Plus上分享。我还是看到有人在Google Plus上加我，所以我知道你们还在用Google Plus。抱歉我从来不回复，因为我从不看它。但你也可以在Patreon上支持我们。
That's right. We have a campaign going on there, and you can get to it from our programmingthrowdown.com. And there, what happens is you can kind of sign up for like, hey, every time there's an episode, I want to give a few dollars per episode. And that helps support the show as well.
没错。我们在那里有一个活动，你可以从我们的 programmingthrowdown.com 访问。在那里，你可以注册，比如，“嘿，每次有新节目，我想每集捐几美元”。这也有助于支持节目。
Keeps it going. That's right. And thank you so much for your support. That's sort of a big part of keeping this whole thing going. We do have pretty high costs, a ton of bandwidth. We use terabytes and terabytes of bandwidth. Yep. And we are working on it.
让它继续下去。没错。非常感谢你们的支持。这是让这一切持续下去的重要部分。我们的成本确实很高，有大量的带宽。我们使用数TB的带宽。是的。我们正在努力解决。
And several of you have written in with helpful suggestions and offers to help and stuff. And if we haven't gotten back to you, sorry. We actually are doing pretty good. We keep sending the emails in. But if we don't reply right away, we apologize. We try to. Yeah, definitely. But some of them might slip through the cracks.
你们中的几个人写信提出了有用的建议和帮助提议。如果我们没有回复你，很抱歉。我们其实做得还不错。我们一直在发送邮件。但如果我们没有立即回复，我们道歉。我们尽量。是的，绝对。但有些可能会漏掉。
Yeah. If you sent an email and we didn't reply, send another email like hey i'm mad at you yeah ping no don't don't say i'm mad at you okay anyways tool of the show tool of the show my tool this show is laverna so um a tool the show in the past um has been-Alt. And if you remember that episode, NV-Alt is a way to keep notes. And it actually, you can write notes in a markdown format and it has a preview mode where you can look at it in a pretty HTML rendering.
是的。如果你发了邮件而我们没有回复，再发一封邮件说“嘿，我生你们气了”。是的，ping一下。不，不要说“我生你们气了”。好吧，总之，本期工具。本期工具是Laverna。过去我们介绍过NV-Alt。如果你还记得那期节目，NV-Alt是一种记笔记的方式。你可以在Markdown格式下写笔记，它有一个预览模式，可以让你以漂亮的HTML渲染效果查看。
It lets you search through your notes. I found it awesome. I came into a situation where I needed something like NV-Alt, but it would also work on Windows and Linux. And NV-Alt is a OS X only tool. So I found Laverna, which is extremely similar. It has a web interface actually no sorry it has a web interface but it also has a native desktop interface it has both and same type of idea where you connect it to your Dropbox
它让你搜索你的笔记。我觉得它很棒。我遇到了一种情况，我需要像NV-Alt这样的东西，但它也要能在Windows和Linux上运行。而NV-Alt是一个仅限OS X的工具。所以我找到了Laverna，它非常相似。它有一个网页界面，不，抱歉，它有一个网页界面，但它也有一个原生桌面界面，两者都有。同样的思路，你把它连接到你的Dropbox
account and it stores all of your notes on Dropbox but it lets you write in Markdown, has full text search all that cool stuff that NVAult has so if you like NVAlt and you want something where you can access your notes on your Linux box at home or what have you, check out Laverna. It's pretty awesome. So there are lots of tools and lots of ways of doing this.
账户，它把所有的笔记存储在Dropbox上，但它让你用Markdown编写，拥有NV-Alt所有的全文搜索等酷炫功能。所以如果你喜欢NV-Alt，并且想要一个能在家里Linux电脑上访问笔记的工具，试试Laverna。它非常棒。所以有很多工具和很多方法可以做到这一点。
But increasingly I'm intrigued by, I think it's Sandstorm. Is that the people doing it the private what cloud or whatever but basically like i haven't heard of this sandstorm yeah you can check it out so i think it's basically kind of like docker but like for personal stuff as opposed to like server stuff um okay and and they're getting they're moving along and i'm not exactly sure how it all works but basically i think they're the closest the idea that like you describing this or whatever but i want i don't want to necessarily run it in a server at home but i want like a server somewhere that i can pay to just however much i need or don't need like an amazon web server small one or something where
但我越来越对Sandstorm感兴趣了。我想是那些做私有云之类的人。基本上，我没听说过这个Sandstorm。是的，你可以去看看。我想它基本上就像Docker，但针对的是个人用途，而不是服务器用途。好吧，他们正在进步，我不确定它具体是怎么运作的，但基本上我认为他们最接近这个想法，就是你描述的这个，但我不想一定要在家里运行服务器，我想要一个我可以付费的远程服务器，根据我的需要，比如亚马逊的小型Web服务器，
like hey i want someone to host my notes and so like i can just install essentially a program on my cloud server but it's my stuff my storage i manage it and like once i either buy the program to install or it's open source like i don't have to worry about the service shutting down or not working like it like my cloud it's my cloud right like it'd be like running a server at home to do all that stuff only it's run somewhere else and there's like a, right? Like, it would be like running a server at home to do all that stuff, only it's run somewhere else, and there's, like, a standard way of adding, like, this sounds bad, like an app store, of, like, adding apps to your cloud, right?
比如“嘿，我想要有人托管我的笔记”，所以我可以在我的云服务器上安装一个程序，但这是我的东西，我的存储，我管理它。一旦我购买了要安装的程序，或者它是开源的，我就不必担心服务关闭或无法工作。就像我的云，这是我的云，对吧？就像在家里运行服务器来做所有这些事情，只是它运行在别的地方，而且有一种标准化的方式来添加，这听起来很糟糕，就像一个应用商店，可以向你的云添加应用程序，对吧？
Oh, I see. Do you kind of see what I'm saying? Like, I feel like there's something there. Yeah, I'm looking at the website now. It's basically like a layer on top of AWS, where instead of, like, AWS, for people to know, it's just, like like they'll give you a Linux machine and you can SSH into it and it's just sitting in the cloud.
哦，我明白了。你明白我的意思吗？我觉得这里面有东西。是的，我正在看网站。它基本上就像是AWS之上的一层，而不是像AWS那样，对于那些不知道的人来说，它只是给你一台Linux机器，你可以通过SSH连接进去，它就坐在云端。
It's always running. And under the hood, if that physical machine dies, they can actually freeze your AWS instance and then start it somewhere else. And so from your perspective, you just have a machine somewhere out there that's always on and so but the issue is you need to be like ssh into the machine you have to be kind of really low level this looks like it's just a layer on top of that where it's like you can just have an application running in the cloud right but in this idea about like having a standardized container as well, right, so that you can get to this kind of quote unquote app store where like, hey, someone releases, you know, there's exactly like in your note editing. It's like, hey, I want to edit notes. I want to be able to go to the web and get to my notes.
它一直在运行。在底层，如果那台物理机器坏了，他们实际上可以冻结你的AWS实例，然后在别处启动它。所以从你的角度来看，你只是在外面有一台一直开着的机器。但问题是你需要SSH进入机器，你必须非常底层。这看起来就像是它之上的一层，你可以直接在云端运行一个应用程序，对吧？但这个关于拥有标准化容器的想法也是，对吧？这样你就可以进入这种所谓的“应用商店”，比如，嘿，有人发布了，你知道，就像你的笔记编辑一样。比如，嘿，我想编辑笔记。我想要能够上网并访问我的笔记。
I want to be able to, you know, have a client on my iPhone, on my Android phone, on my, you know, OSX box that edits the notes. And they all go back to my cloud. That way I don't have to worry about like, hey, what happens if this free service decides to go down or start charging or whatever? Like it's mine, right? Like once I'm running this program, I control it. Yeah, that makes sense. And if I use up all my storage, I just get more, right?
我想要在我的iPhone、Android手机、OSX电脑上有一个客户端来编辑笔记。它们都回到我的云端。这样我就不必担心，嘿，如果这个免费服务决定关闭或开始收费怎么办？它是我的，对吧？一旦我运行了这个程序，我就控制了它。是的，这很有道理。如果我用完了存储空间，我只需要买更多，对吧？
Yeah, I don't know yeah very cool sandstorm that's another i'll add it to the tool of the show sorry that was a sidetrack no i think it's awesome i'm really glad i need to look into it more i haven't looked into it but i the idea is and like as i read it and then it's like i don't know if what i took away from sandstorm is what it's actually for but that's what stuck in my head and then i I've just been, like, having this idea in the back of my head. Yeah, no, I mean, it's pretty much exactly what you described. It looks very cool. So I don't, yeah, so that was nothing about Laverna.
是的，我不知道，非常酷。Sandstorm，这是另一个，我会把它加到本期工具里。抱歉，刚才跑题了。不，我觉得这很棒。我很高兴，我需要深入研究一下。我还没研究过，但我的想法是，当我读到它时，我不知道我从Sandstorm中理解的是不是它真正的用途，但这就是我脑子里留下的印象。我一直有这个想法。是的，不，我的意思是，这和你描述的几乎一模一样。看起来很酷。所以，关于Laverna就没什么可说的了。
That could be my tool of the show. I spent a lot of time talking about it. I'll save my other one for next time. So I don't know anything about Sandstorm, but it's my tool of the show because it sounds awesome. And it's free, and I normally do video games that you have to pay for. It looks totally cool. So my tool of the show is that you have to go do work and look up what Sandstorm is
那可以作为我的本期工具。我花了很多时间谈论它。我会把另一个留到下次。所以我对Sandstorm一无所知，但它是我的本期工具，因为它听起来很棒。而且它是免费的，我通常介绍的是需要付费的电子游戏。它看起来非常酷。所以我的本期工具就是，你必须去工作，查查Sandstorm是什么，
and then tell me that I'm crazy or awesome. All right. Now you know what to do. Email Patrick. You can find his email from the website and tell him whether he's cool, whether he, what was it? No, you don't need to tell me. I already know. I've been being told my whole life um today so on to the
然后告诉我我是疯了还是太棒了。好了，现在你知道该做什么了。给Patrick发邮件。你可以从网站上找到他的邮箱，告诉他他是否很酷，是否……那是什么？不，你不需要告诉我。我早就知道了。我这辈子一直都被人这么说。嗯，今天，继续……
uh scientific python scientific python um so you know we have a show on python um since then we've done shows on matlab and r um and we're going to do a show on julia we've gotten tons of requests on that and so i think it's good to talk about oh i want to say something on that two things one a lot of people have written in for like follow-up shows like you know version two and i think this kind of qualifies as that for python like yeah going more in depth so so this is kind of the answer to that and we'll start with python um the second thing is like oh you talk about like a lot of people writing about julia and um that's right and and one of the things like programming thread and we do explore a lot of things but one of the things
呃，科学Python。科学Python。所以你知道我们有一个关于Python的节目，从那以后我们做了关于MATLAB和R的节目，我们还要做一个关于Julia的节目，我们收到了很多关于这个的请求。所以我认为谈谈这个很好。哦，我想说两件事。第一，很多人写信要求做后续节目，比如第二版，我认为这对于Python来说算得上是这样，比如更深入地探讨。所以这是对那个的回应，我们将从Python开始。第二件事是，你谈到很多人写信询问Julia，没错。而且编程Throwdown探索了很多东西，但我发现最重要的事情之一是社区的临界质量，以及它如何……通过这次Python讨论，在Python中做这些事情的好处之一是Python拥有临界质量。如果你有一个问题，很可能其他人也遇到过，所以你能很快找到答案。没错，没错。所以虽然我们谈论其他东西，因为了解其他情况并在你的工具箱里有其他工具总是好的，但关注某个事物背后的社区规模也确实很好。是的，特别是你知道，通过使用科学Python，你正在利用通用的Python社区。所以如果你……我的意思是，当你进行任何类型的科学分析时，你仍然必须做一些集成工作。或者你可以说，
i find most important is like critical mass of like community and how that like with this python discussion one of the nice things about doing these things in python is python has critical mass like if you have a problem chances are other people have also had the problem and so you'll be able to find your answer very quickly that's right that's right so although we talk about other stuff because it's always good to keep abreast of other situations and have other tools in your bag it is really nice to also pay attention to how much community there is behind a given thing yep and and especially you know by using scientific python you're leveraging the general python community so if you you know i mean when you do any type of scientific analysis you still have to do some integration work as well. Or you can say like,
我认为最重要的是社区的临界质量，以及它如何与这次Python讨论相关联。使用Python做这些事情的好处之一是Python拥有临界质量，如果你遇到了问题，很可能其他人也遇到过，所以你能很快找到答案。没错，没错，所以尽管我们讨论其他东西，因为随时了解其他情况并在工具箱里准备其他工具总是好的，但关注某件事物背后的社区规模也非常重要。是的，特别是你知道，通过使用科学Python，你是在利用整个Python社区，所以如果你，我的意思是，当你进行任何类型的科学分析时，你仍然需要做一些集成工作。或者你可以说，比如，
I need to open a file or. Yeah. Or, or, you know, my, my data is in HDF five format. And so I need a loader for that or something.
我需要打开一个文件，或者……是的。或者，你知道，我的数据是HDF5格式的。所以我需要一个加载器之类的。
Or I have to get my data from Hadoop or something. Right. And so, so all of these things in general are much easier to do in Python than, say, like MATLAB or R or some other very specific kind of environment. So, yes, so there's two main interfaces to doing scientific work in Python. One is the command line. So keep in mind, so when I say scientific work, I'm talking about, you know, analysis where you want to, yeah, you want, you have some data, you slice the data one way, you get some results, you slice the data another way,
或者我必须从Hadoop获取数据之类的。没错。所以所有这些事情通常在Python中比在MATLAB或R或其他非常特定的环境中要容易得多。所以，是的，在Python中进行科学工作有两个主要界面。一个是命令行。所以记住，当我提到科学工作时，我指的是分析，你想……是的，你想……你有一些数据，你以一种方式切分数据，得到一些结果，你以另一种方式切分数据，
you get another result. And you're not really writing code that you're going to keep. I mean, you're writing scripts and you might want to keep it mean you're writing scripts and and you might want to keep it as a reference but it's really you're trying to um learn something about some data and it usually involves very fast iteration trying many different things learning a lot and then and hopefully it comes out plotting or something right that's right what comes out of it is some kind of visualization or several visualizations. Or a table. Yep. So that can involve logs analysis too, right?
你得到另一个结果。你并不是真的在写你要保留的代码。我的意思是，你在写脚本，你可能想保留它……我的意思是，你在写脚本，你可能想把它作为参考，但你实际上是在试图了解关于某些数据的一些信息，它通常涉及非常快速的迭代，尝试许多不同的事情，学习很多，然后希望它能产生绘图之类的，对吧？没错，产生的结果是某种可视化或几个可视化。或者一个表格。是的。所以这也可能涉及日志分析，对吧？
What is the most common time that people come to my website, right? Yep. Yeah, so scientific doesn't just mean collection of science experiments. That's a good point. Yeah, totally, totally. So this is where this sort of data scientist term comes from. It's like, you know, your web logs can be sort of a medium by which you do this data science. And so it's not, yeah, you're not talking about like protein analysis or something like that. Although you could be. Yeah, I mean, it's greater scope than that.
人们访问我网站的最常见时间是什么，对吧？是的。是的，所以科学并不意味着仅仅是科学实验的集合。这是一个很好的观点。是的，完全正确。所以这就是“数据科学家”这个词的由来。就像，你知道，你的网络日志可以成为你进行这种数据科学的媒介。所以它不是……是的，你不是在谈论蛋白质分析之类的。虽然你也可以是。是的，我的意思是，它的范围比那更大。
So it includes that, but also looking at your website and seeing how popular it is and things like that. So one interface is the command line. This is just where you type Python, you hit Enter, and you get a prompt, and you can run all sorts of commands in there. That is okay, but there's several others that are better. So one is spider. And this is...
所以它包括了这些，但也包括查看你的网站并了解它有多受欢迎等等。所以一个界面是命令行。这就是你输入Python，按回车，然后得到一个提示符，你可以在里面运行各种命令。这还可以，但有几个更好的。一个是Spyder。这是……
And that's with a Y, spider with a Y. Yep, spider with a Y. And this is actually similar to MATLAB. So if you're used to using MATLAB, I actually just started using Spyder a week ago Patrick mentioned it to me last week and I checked it out, it's amazing
那是带Y的，Spyder带Y。没错，Spyder带Y。这实际上类似于MATLAB。所以如果你习惯使用MATLAB，我其实一周前才开始使用Spyder，Patrick上周向我提到了它，我试了一下，它太棒了。
it gives you a nice MATLAB interface where you can see variables that you've most recently used, just like in MATLAB you can inspect them and things like that I'm good, I'm glad I didn't send you down a rabbit trail no, it's totally awesome it runs on your spec them and things like that. I'm good. I'm glad I didn't send you down a rabbit trail. No, it's totally awesome.
它为你提供了一个很好的MATLAB界面，你可以看到你最近使用过的变量，就像在MATLAB中一样，你可以检查它们等等。我很高兴，我很高兴我没有把你带进死胡同。不，它太棒了，它在你的桌面上运行，就像MATLAB一样。还有Jupyter，以前叫IPython Notebook。Jupyter非常类似于Mathematica Notebook，如果你用过的话。Mathematica是另一个科学
It runs on your desktop, just like MATLAB. There's also Jupyter, which used to be called IPython Notebook. Jupyter is very similar to Mathematica Notebook, if you've ever used that. Mathematica is another scientific
计算平台。所以，Mathematica Notebook和Jupyter的想法非常棒，假设你正在做一些数据分析，你有不同的阶段。第一阶段，你加载数据。第二阶段，你做了一堆转换，对吧？在第三阶段，你创建一些可视化。所以回到Patrick的例子，第一阶段，你从Apache加载所有的网络日志。第二阶段，你计算一些直方图，计算直方图和读取所有日志可能需要一个小时。这是一个非常受欢迎的网站。然后，当然。
computational platform. So, the idea with the Mathematica is another scientific computational platform. So the idea with the Mathematica notebook and with Jupyter that's super awesome is, let's say you're doing some data analysis and you have different stages. The first stage, you're loading in data. The second stage, you're doing a bunch of transformations, right? And in the third stage, you're creating some visualization. So going back to Patrick's example, the first stage, you're loading all of your web logs from Apache. The second stage, you're computing some histogram, and it takes maybe an hour to compute a histogram and read all the logs. It's a very popular website. And then, sure.
然后第三阶段，你绘制它，对吧？所以假设你绘制了它，图表是正确的，但看起来不太好。比如你可能想要蓝色的线条之类的。你实际上可以重新运行那个生成图表的第三个单元格，它可以获取第二个单元格的结果。换句话说，如果你把数据分成这些单元格，每次你完成一个单元格，它就会冻结一切并说，
And then the third stage, you're plotting it, right? So let's say you plot it, and the plot is correct, but it just doesn't look very good. Like maybe you want the line to be blue or something. You can actually rerun that third cell that generates the plot, and it can take the results from the second cell. So in other words, if you have your data broken up into these cells, every time you finish one cell, it sort of freezes everything and says,
“好的，我完成了这个单元格，下次我需要运行它后面的单元格时，我知道该怎么做，从哪里开始。”所以你可以调整你的图表100次，而不必运行整个代码库。你只需要运行绘图部分，这非常重要。我认为笔记本风格的另一个重要之处在于，人们通常在程序中只能看到输出，
okay, I finished this cell, and the next time I need to run the cell after it, I know what to do, like where to start. And so you can tweak your plot 100 different times without having to run your entire code base. You can just run the plot part, which is really important. The other important thing, I think, with the notebook style that can be really cool is that people, often with programs, you just see the output
对吧？就像你只能看到“哦，这是我的数据集，这是图表”，有时这很好，你可以从笔记本中得到它，但有时人们想看到你经历的过程，对吧？甚至中间图表，比如首先数据看起来像这样，然后我应用了这个过滤器，它
right like you just see oh here's my data set and here's the graph and sometimes that's good and you can get that from the notebook but other times people want to see the process you went through right or even intermediate graphs like first the data looks like this then I apply this filter and it
看起来像那样。看到你这样做，看到你经历的步骤被冻结，你知道，可见，甚至在某些方面是交互式的，这真的很有用。是的，有些单元格甚至不需要是Python，你实际上可以有纯文本的单元格。所以你可以有一个单元格做各种计算，然后下一个单元格只是描述前一个单元格中发生了什么。你可以有一个单元格做各种计算，然后下一个单元格只是描述前一个单元格中发生了什么。你实际上可以把你的IPython Notebook发给别人，现在他们就有了
looks like that and seeing you kind of do that like seeing the steps you go through frozen and you know visible and then even interactive in some ways is really useful yep and some of the cells don't even have to be python you can actually have cells that are just text so you can have a cell doing all sorts of computation and then the next cell just describes what happened in the previous cell and you can have a cell doing all sorts of computation, and then the next cell just describes what happened in the previous cell. And you can actually take your IPython notebook and send it to somebody, and now they have
你的源代码，可能还有你的数据，以及你的文档，都在一个文件里，这很酷。所以这些是一些界面。现在，大多数科学库或科学平台都有一个张量库。所以这意味着，对于不知道的人来说，张量只是一个高维矩阵。所以如果你有，比如，假设你有一个点。所以一个点有X，点有XYZ坐标，就像3D中的某个点，那将是一个向量，这也叫向量。所以这
your source code, potentially your data, and your documentation all in one file, which is pretty cool. So those are some of the interfaces. Now, most scientific libraries or scientific platforms have a tensor library. So what this means is, for people who don't know, a tensor is just a higher dimensional matrix. So if you have sort of, let's say you have a point. So a point has x, point has XYZ coordinates like some point in 3d so that would be a vector that's also called a vector and so this
是一个一维数字数组，XYZ，对吧？你可以有一个矩阵，它是二维的，所以它有行和列，每个元素是一个单元格，有点像Excel电子表格是一个矩阵，对吧？但你可能需要三维、四维或五维的数字。所以这些被称为张量。所以有一些库可以非常快地进行张量运算。这对于任何类型的科学计算通常都是至关重要的。所以最流行的是NumPy。
is one dimensional array of numbers XYZ right you can have a matrix which is two dimensions so it has rows and columns and each element is a cell, kind of like Excel spreadsheet is a matrix, right? But then you might need three dimensions of numbers or four dimensions or five dimensions. So these are called tensors. And so there are libraries out there that do tensor operations very fast. And this is often critical for any type of scientific computing. So the most popular is NumPy.
NumPy非常类似于MATLAB。所以如果你有使用MATLAB的经验，或者即使你有使用R的经验，你在NumPy也会感到宾至如归。关于NumPy需要知道的是它超级快，而且它快是因为你对矩阵或向量进行操作。换句话说，假设我有两个向量，两个数字列表，我称之为列表A和列表B，我想把它们……比如我想把列表的每个分量相加并产生一个新的列表C。如果我在Python中写一个for循环，我只是说for，你知道，
NumPy is very similar to MATLAB. So if you have experience using MATLAB, or even if you have experience using R, you'll be right at home with NumPy. The thing to know about NumPpy is it's super fast and and it's fast because it you do operations on matrices or vectors so in other words let's say i have two vectors two lists of numbers i'll just call it list a and list b and i want to them, like I want to add each component of the list and produce a new list C. So if I write a for loop in Python, I just say for, you know,
一到一百万，C[i] = A[i] + B[i]。那需要很长时间。我的意思是，那可能需要一秒钟。即使对于一百万个数字，那也很长。如果你有……你知道，一GB的数据，那可能需要三天之类的，那需要超级长的时间。但你不必那样做，
one to a million, C of I equals A of I plus B of I. That's going to take a long time. I mean, that's going to take maybe a second. Even for a million numbers, that's a long time. If you have have you know a gigabyte of data it's going to take three days or something it's going to take a super long time but you don't have to do that
用NumPy，如果它们是NumPy数组，你可以字面上只说C = A + B，在底层它会把它变成超级超级快的C代码，它会把它变成超级、超级快的C代码，直接扫过那些数据。它会
with numpy if they're numpy arrays you can literally just say c equals a plus b and under the hood it's going to turn that into super super fast c code, it's going to turn that into super, super fast C code that's just going to blitz through that data. It's going to
使用你电脑上的特殊SIMD处理器。我的意思是，它会从一秒钟变得快到你甚至无法测量。你知道，比如不到一毫秒。所以虽然人们说Python慢，他们是对的。Python通常确实比C慢得多。NumPy只是快得不可思议。你永远不应该因为性能原因而回避NumPy或科学Python。更具体地说，快是一个任意的
use special SIMD processors on your computer. And I mean, it's going to go from a second to so fast you can't even measure it. You know, like less than a millisecond. So although people say Python less than a millisecond.
词，但高效，高效意味着做同样的操作需要多少指令，如果你能用更少的指令完成，那会更好，或者所谓的“更快”，但它仍然可能……我的意思是，如果你使用大数据，它仍然可能需要很长时间。那是真的。是的，完全正确。所以也许这有点傻，但这里的“快”只是意味着在Python中，你的CPU每行Python代码必须执行比每行C代码更多的指令，这是一个模糊的通用规则。没错，没错。所以NumPy就在那里。还有Theano，它是建立在NumPy之上的，并为你提供GPU支持。我们将来会更多地谈论GPU。
Although people say Python is slow, and they're right. Python is definitely much slower than C in general. NumPy is just incredibly fast. You should never shy away from NumPy or from scientific Python for performance reasons. To be a little more specific, fast is an arbitrary
我认为我们可以涵盖很多内容。但简短的故事是，GPU和张量配合得非常好。GPU旨在进行矩阵运算。完全正确。完全正确。所以移动三角形全都是关于矩阵乘法。是的。所以Theano将让你使用你的NumPy代码，它已经……不快，但它在你的CPU上运行。它将让你在GPU上运行它，这可以给你带来相当显著的速度提升。
word, but efficient efficient which would be like how many instructions it takes to do the same operation and if you could do it in less then that would be better or quote-unquote faster but it still might be i mean if you're using big data it could still take a long time that's true yep yeah totally so maybe that's a little goofy, but fast here just means like in Python, your CPU has to execute more instructions per line of Python than per line of C as a vague general rule. Right, right. So NumPy is there. There's Theano, which is built on top of NumPy and gives you GPU support. We'll talk more about GPUs in the future.
Theano是一个大学项目，所以文档不是很好。它有很多那种丑陋的遗留代码。所以有一个叫TensorFlow的东西，它是谷歌的产品。它是完全免费的，它解决了和Theano相同的用例，但它有很棒的文档，记录得非常好。他们有非常适合初学者的教程。
I think there's a lot we could cover there. But the short story is that GPUs and tensors go together really well. GPUs are meant to do matrix operations. Exactly. Exactly. And so moving the triangles around is all about matrix multiplying. Yep. And so the ano will let you take your NumPy code, which is already no fast, but it's running on your CPU. And it will let you run it on the GPU and that can give you pretty dramatic speedups.
所以如果有人现在开始一个新项目，我绝对会告诉他们使用TensorFlow。TensorFlow，请继续。所以TensorFlow，就像你说的，有很多矩阵运算之类的，但我总是看到……是的，所以它也是机器学习，对吧？所以机器学习
Theano is a university project and so documentation isn't great. It has a lot of sort of legacy code that's kind of ugly. So there's something called TensorFlow which is a Google product. It's totally free and it solves the same use case as Theano, but it has amazing documentation, very well documented. They have tutorials that are great for beginners.
也涉及到使用大量的矩阵和矩阵运算。TensorFlow是设计用来处理这个的吗，还是它两者都处理，比如它更通用？我其实还没研究过。当然。它更通用。他们确实有机器学习的库。
And so if someone was starting a new project now, I would definitely tell them to use TensorFlow. TensorFlow, go ahead. So TensorFlow, like you said, has a lot of matrix operations and stuff, but I always see... Yeah, so is it machine learning also, right? So machine learning
即使Theano也有一些非常特定于机器学习的函数。但你可以把TensorFlow用于任何事情。所以这些就是那种能给你那种MATLAB
also gets into using a lot of matrices and matrix operations. Is TensorFlow designed to kind of handle that, or it handles both, like it's more generic? I haven't actually looked into it. Sure. It's more generic. They do have libraries for machine learning.
或R那种性能的张量库。所以还有一些科学库可以帮助以更复杂的方式操作这些矩阵和张量。最流行的是SciPy。SciPy也是建立在NumPy之上的。它为你提供了一些东西，比如积分。所以如果你有一个分布，你想对它进行积分，你可以做到。它进行优化。所以如果你有一组点，你想拟合一条曲线到这些点，并且你想最小化点到曲线的距离，所以你想让那条曲线尽可能接近穿过这些点，它可以做到。它有一堆信号处理，比如低通滤波器、高通滤波器、FFT。
Even Theano has some functions that are very specific to machine learning. But you can use TensorFlow for anything. Those are victim machine learning. But you can use TensorFlow for anything. So those are sort of the tensor libraries that would give you kind of that MATLAB
它有大量的这些不同的系统。嗯，令人困惑的是，其中一些在NumPy中，但NumPy和SciPy在某种程度上是紧密结合的，或者至少在我看来是这样。我不知道确切的区别是什么。是的，那确实有点令人困惑。但搜索是你的朋友。是的，那是真的。
or R kind of like performance. So some more scientific libraries to sort of help manipulate these matrices and these tensors in more complex ways. The most popular is SciPy. SciPy is also built on top of NumPy. It gives you things like integration. So if you have some distribution and you want to integrate it, you can do that. It does optimization. So if you have a set of points and you want to fit a curve to those points and you want to minimize the distance from the points to the curve, so you want that curve to be as close as possible to going through those points, it can do that. It has a bunch of signal processing, like low-pass filter, high-pass filter, FFTs.
绝对，是的，你必须做大量的谷歌搜索。我想说这是科学Python的一个缺点，因为它是碎片化的，没有一个单一的机构在说，“好的，这就是我们要如何布局一切”。所以确实需要一点谷歌搜索才能上手。但是的，SciPy有各种各样的统计数据。如果你想从泊松分布中抽取，比如你想从泊松分布中抽取100个数字，
It has a ton of these different systems. Well, confusingly, some of those are in NumPy, but NumPy and SciPy are kind of joined at the hip, or at least in my mind. I don't know what the exact difference is. Yeah, that is kind of confusing. But search is your friend. Yeah, that's true.
只需要一行代码就能得到。它可以给你分布的CCF。任何与统计相关的东西，SciPy都能做到。它还有很好的线性或稀疏线性代数库。所以有时候，比如，回到访问你的网站。假设你有一个数组，每一秒，数组包含那一秒访问你网站的人数。嗯，其中很多会是零，
Definitely, yeah, you'll have to do a lot of Googling. That is one nice thing I would say. That's one sort of con of scientific Python is that because it's fragmented, there isn't just sort of one body that's saying, okay, here's how we're going to lay everything out. So it does take a little bit of googling to sort of get your hands wet. But yes, SciPy has all sorts of statistics. If you want to draw from like a Poisson distribution, you want 100 numbers drawn from a Poisson distribution,
取决于你的网站。但如果你的网站不是超级受欢迎，很多这些值将是零。所以存储所有这些零或对所有这些零做任何事情将是非常昂贵的。所以SciPy实际上有一个稀疏线性代数库。所以它只存储非零值。当它进行运算时，它在某种程度上理解那种结构。
there's just a one-liner that just gives that to you. It can give you CCFs of distributions. Anything statistics related you need SciPy can do it. It also has good linear or sparse linear algebra libraries. So there are times where, let's say for example, going back to the visiting your website. Let's say you have some array where every second, what the array contain a number of how many people visit your website that second. Well, a lot of those are going to be zero,
所以如果你把两个数组相加，它只会相加非零值，诸如此类。这在科学的某些分支中变得至关重要，因为矩阵变得非常非常大。所以关于Sparse，我总是记得的一件事，这是一种有趣的方式，如果你考虑康威生命游戏，如果你考虑在一个任意大的棋盘上玩它，你会如何表示，
depending on your website. But if your website isn't uber popular, a lot of those values will be zero. And so storing all these zeros or doing anything with all these zeros is going to be very expensive. So SciPy actually has a sparse linear algebra library. So it only stores the non-zeros. And when it does operations, it kind of understands sort of that structure.
比如你会如何执行这些操作？我不知道。许多早期的编程课程会带你实现康威生命游戏，你通常只是使用数组的数组或二维数组，嗯，你照做了，但如果棋盘真的真的非常大，会发生什么？你会如何高效地做它？对吧，这总是我脑子里的一种方式，我可以联系起来，因为很多科学对我来说是遥不可及的。所以，正如Jason所说，
So if you add two arrays, it will only add the non-zeros, things like that. And this becomes critical in some branches of science because the matrices grow really, really big. So the thing I always remember about Sparse, which is an interesting way, is if you think about Conway's Game of Life, and if you think about playing it on basically an arbitrarily large board, how would you represent,
你基本上只跟踪和操作那些非零的地方，而零甚至没有被显式表示。是的，所以另一件事是Pandas。
like how would you perform the operations? I don't know. A lot of early programming courses kind of take you through implementing conway's game of life and you typically just use an array of arrays or a two-dimensional array um and you kind of do it but what would happen if the board was really really really big uh how would you do it efficiently right and that's always kind of one of the things that in my mind is a way i can relate that because a lot of the science is out of reach for me so and it's just as Jason said
Pandas很酷。如果你用过R，你就知道什么是数据框（Data Frame）。如果没有，我无法解释。数据框，把它想象成内存中的SQL数据库。如果你上过SQL课，我想我们之前在节目中介绍过SQL。在SQL中，你可能会做类似“选择年龄在18岁及以上的用户名”的操作。你最终得到的是所有18岁及以上用户的列表。显然，它超级酷，但有很多时候你不想使用……
you basically only track and operate on the places which are non-zero and the zeros just aren't even represented explicitly yep so another thing is pandas
你基本上只跟踪和操作非零的位置，而零甚至不会被显式地表示出来。是的，还有一件事是Pandas
pandas is pretty cool. If you've ever used R, you know what a data frame is. If not, I can't explain it. A data frame is, think of it like a SQL database in memory. If you've ever taken a SQL class, I think we actually covered SQL on a previous show. In SQL, you might do something like select the username where the age is 18 and up. What you end up with is a list of all your 18 years and older users. Obviously, it's super cool, but there's many times where you don't want to be using
Pandas非常酷。如果你用过R，你就知道什么是数据框（data frame）。如果没有，我没法解释。数据框，你可以把它想象成内存中的SQL数据库。如果你上过SQL课，我想我们之前节目里其实讲过SQL。在SQL中，你可能会做类似“选择年龄在18岁及以上的用户名”这样的操作。你最终得到的是所有18岁及以上用户的列表。显然，它非常酷，但有很多时候你并不想使用它
SQL. You don't want to have to query your SQL database every time you want some data just because they have a nice interface, right? Because you have to go out to the network to get that data. It's kind of painful. So maybe an easy thing would be if you could have a SQL database, but it's just sitting in your memory. And when you do that select, it's just instantaneous,
SQL。你肯定不想每次需要数据时都去查询SQL数据库，仅仅因为它们有一个不错的接口，对吧？因为你必须通过网络去获取那些数据，这有点麻烦。所以，如果能有一个直接驻留在内存中的SQL数据库，那可能会更方便。当你执行SELECT查询时，它是瞬间完成的，
or just very quick, because it's just really doing an in-memory lookup. And so that's what Pandas does. So with Pandas, you load your data into a data frame. And then you can do what's called pivoting which is similar to doing kind of like select statements and you can slice and erase your data very quickly the handle is also the handle's reading and writing in post formats so once you have your data in a data frame you can write it out to HF5, you can write
或者非常快，因为它实际上是在进行内存查找。这就是Pandas所做的。使用Pandas，你可以将数据加载到数据帧（DataFrame）中，然后进行所谓的“透视”（pivoting），这类似于执行SELECT语句，你可以非常快速地切片和处理数据。Pandas还支持多种格式的读写，所以一旦数据进入数据帧，你就可以将其写入HF5，或者写入
it out to SQL scripts, to CSV, and it goes the other way too. You can take a whole SQL database that you serialized to CSV, to SQL, and you can read it into a data frame using Pandas. So Pandas, if you're doing any type of data analysis, it's absolutely essential, and it's very well done. This last one is kind of specific. It's PyMC. And this is for Bayesian models. We talked about accept-read-exampling. We've talked about some other Bayesian methods in the past. So PyMC basically just makes it super easy and it's pretty cool how it works.
SQL脚本、CSV文件，反之亦然。你可以获取整个序列化为CSV或SQL的数据库，并使用Pandas将其读入数据帧。因此，如果你在做任何类型的数据分析，Pandas是绝对必不可少的，而且它做得非常好。最后一个工具比较特殊，叫PyMC，它是用于贝叶斯模型的。我们过去讨论过接受-拒绝采样（accept-reject sampling）以及其他一些贝叶斯方法。PyMC基本上让这一切变得超级简单，它的工作方式非常酷。
One thing you can do is, let's say you want to do some analysis on a bowling tie. So if you had a race, you'd just say, numpy, give me a random number between 1 and 6. And it says 2. That doesn't really tell you anything. You just want your number. See, that's what you want to know. That's sort of if you roll two dice.
你可以做的一件事是，假设你想对掷骰子进行一些分析。如果你进行一次掷骰，你只需说：NumPy，给我一个1到6之间的随机数。它返回2。这其实说明不了什么。你只是想要一个数字。看，这就是你想知道的。如果你掷两个骰子，情况就是这样。
But what that distribution looks like. If you roll two dice, how often do you get 6 as the sum? 6 versus 2, right? You could actually, in my PC, you can say x equals, you know, random number from 1 to 6 plus random number from 1 to 6. And then you can say it is the distribution of x. And it will just, you know, run a bunch of simulations, and just show you what that looks like. So it's just super easy. You don't have to have to build a lot of simulations.
但分布看起来是什么样的呢？如果你掷两个骰子，得到和为6的概率是多少？6和2相比如何？实际上，在PyMC中，你可以说x等于1到6的随机数加上1到6的随机数。然后你可以说这是x的分布。它会自动运行一堆模拟，并向你展示结果。这超级简单，你不需要自己构建大量的模拟。
You don't have to deal with running the same thing parallel and all the time. It does all that for you. You just write a bunch of equation equations and random numbers, and then at the end you just say, show me a few different ways that this answer exists.
你不需要处理并行运行相同任务的问题，它会为你完成所有这些工作。你只需要写出一堆方程和随机数，最后说：给我展示几种这个答案存在的可能性。
And it just does magic magic. Magic. Magic. Almost always the output of all of this analysis is some sort of visualization. We already kind of said that. So one of the tools that's used to generate those visualizations is matplotlib it has almost identical as far as i know function parameters as matlab and so you can you know plot a graph set the color set the weight of the line set how you want the points used or drawn. And it's not particularly fast, so if you have like a dynamic signal,
它就会施展魔法。魔法。魔法。几乎所有这些分析的输出都是某种可视化。我们之前已经提到了。用于生成这些可视化的工具之一是Matplotlib。据我所知，它的函数参数与Matlab几乎完全相同，所以你可以绘制图表、设置颜色、设置线条粗细、设置点的使用或绘制方式。它不是特别快，所以如果你有一个动态信号，
you wouldn't want to, you know, plot it over and over again. It's kind of slow for doing that, but for plotting the results of a whole bunch of computation like we've been talking about in this context, it works really well. Yeah, you're totally right. Another cool visualization tool is panoramics. Yeah, you're totally right. Another cool visualization tool is Panoramics. So Panoramics is a little bit different. It's not a library, so it's not like while you're writing code you just make a call to
你肯定不想一遍又一遍地绘制它。那样做有点慢，但对于像我们在这个语境下讨论的那样，绘制大量计算结果来说，它非常有效。是的，你说得完全对。另一个很酷的可视化工具是Panoramics。是的，你说得完全对。另一个很酷的可视化工具是Panoramics。Panoramics有点不同。它不是一个库，所以不像你在写代码时直接调用它那样，
Panoramics. It doesn't really work that way. Instead what you do is you export your data using something like pandas and then you have a panoramic service that's running and you point it to your data and then it will give you a bunch of visualizations so the drawback is you can't just make a call into it it's not lightweight but on the flip side it's very very full featured so you actually if you specify the type of your data, so if you say, for example, these are lat-long, latitude, longitude points,
Panoramics不是那样工作的。相反，你需要使用像Pandas这样的工具导出数据，然后运行一个Panoramics服务，将它指向你的数据，它就会为你提供一系列可视化效果。缺点是你不能直接调用它，它不是轻量级的，但另一方面，它功能非常全面。所以，如果你指定了数据的类型，例如，如果你说这些是经纬度点，
then it will actually generate a map using, I guess, Google Maps or something. It will actually generate a map, and it will put hot areas on the map where you have a lot of points and cold areas where you don't, things like that um it'll generate a bunch of different charts and and ways to slice and dice the data it's really cool um so i highly recommend it well that's all i got for uh scientific python yeah so um you know if you uh one thing to keep in mind is no matter what you choose to do with respect to you know programming or engineering you'll eventually have to do this i mean if you
那么它实际上会使用谷歌地图或类似的东西生成一张地图。它会生成一张地图，并在地图上标出点密集的热点区域和点稀疏的冷点区域，诸如此类。它会生成各种不同的图表以及切片和分析数据的方法。它真的很酷，所以我强烈推荐它。好了，关于科学Python的内容就这些了。是的，嗯，你知道，无论你在编程或工程方面选择做什么，你最终都必须做这些工作。我的意思是，如果你
build a website you're eventually going to have to count how many people visit your website i mean if you're building it and trying to grow it um no matter what you do, you're going to need to do some type of analysis. And so if you take a bit of time to learn scientific Python and this kind of stack, it'll be just incredibly valuable for anything that you want to do in the future. And as Jason pointed out, often, and it's not always the case, but in my experience, often these are the things you want to know how to do quickly because this is throwaway code like it's code you write once and do the analysis and then you kind of next time you need to do the analysis it will have changed differently enough significantly enough that you likely can't just run the same thing again at least that's been my experience and And that comes down to a judgment call between writing something that you plan to maintain and that you want to be, let's call it well-written,
建立一个网站，你最终必须统计有多少人访问你的网站。我的意思是，如果你正在构建它并试图发展它，无论你做什么，你都需要进行某种分析。所以，如果你花点时间学习科学Python和这种技术栈，这对你未来想做的任何事情都将非常有价值。正如Jason指出的那样，通常情况下——虽然不总是这样，但在我的经验中——这些是你需要快速掌握的东西，因为这通常是“一次性代码”。也就是说，你写代码做一次分析，下次需要做分析时，情况可能已经发生了显著变化，以至于你很可能无法再次运行相同的代码。至少这是我的经验。这归结于一个判断：你是写一段打算维护、写得好、
and it's going to stay for a while, and something that you mean to build to produce an output and then destroy the process or whatever. Yeah, you're totally right. So yeah, I mean, getting more adept at this increases like your productivity dramatically yep well thanks y'all for listening yeah thank you for the feedback um we hope to do more interviews a lot of the feedback we've gotten recently has been you know the interviews are great and and we appreciate that uh we we are
并且会长期存在的代码，还是写一段旨在产生输出然后销毁过程的代码。是的，你说得完全对。所以，变得更擅长这些确实会极大地提高你的生产力。是的，谢谢大家的收听。是的，感谢大家的反馈。我们希望能做更多的采访。最近我们收到的很多反馈都是说采访很棒，我们对此非常感激。我们
listening and so um you know we can so we could do an interview this month, and nor would we want to do an interview every single month. But actually, we've had a lot of fun doing interviews, and we hope to have an interview lined up next month. That's right. And people have written in and kind of said, like, oh, more technical, or, oh, I like it. That's less technical. But I mean, I think I've listened to other interview podcasts and things on the Internet and people get very technical or whatever.
在倾听。所以，我们这个月可以做一次采访，我们也不想每个月都做采访。但实际上，我们做采访玩得很开心，我们希望下个月能安排一次采访。没错。人们写信来说，比如“哦，更技术性一点”或者“哦，我喜欢它，没那么技术性”。但我认为我听过互联网上其他的采访播客，人们会变得非常技术化之类的。
And that's cool. But I feel like we bring our own brand of interviewing by kind of keeping it light, but also technical. Right. And hopefully these are the kind of conversations that I have with Jason, the kind of conversations I have at work. So maybe you enjoy that. Maybe you would be like, dude, it'd be cool to work with Patrick and Jason. Or maybe you're like, no, I hate these guys. Like, they must not get any work done.
那很酷。但我感觉我们通过保持轻松但同时兼顾技术性，带来了我们自己风格的采访。没错。希望这些是我和Jason进行的对话，也是我在工作中进行的对话。所以也许你会喜欢。也许你会想：“伙计，和Patrick与Jason一起工作会很酷。”或者也许你会想：“不，我讨厌这些人。他们肯定什么工作都做不成。”
You're probably right. Or if you're in school and you're like, you know, hey, what is it like to, you know, kind of be on a team of programming aside from a team doing programming aside from the actual programming? Hopefully we bring that to your lives. Yeah, absolutely. a team doing programming aside from the actual programming hopefully we bring that to your lives yeah absolutely i mean one thing that's kind of obvious and and and uh um obvious to people who have been in industry a while is that what your job is uh is definitely not what you expect it to be when you're in college and i mean this is true of any job i mean look at say basketball player um a basketball player spends a ton of time doing like autographs you know agents uh you know uh doing all these different like book signing or you know t-shirt signings all
你可能是对的。或者如果你还在上学，你会想：“嘿，除了实际的编程之外，在一个编程团队里工作是什么感觉？”希望我们能把这些带进你们的生活。是的，绝对。我的意思是，对于在行业里待了一段时间的人来说，有一点很明显，那就是你的工作绝对不是你在大学时所期望的那样。我的意思是，任何工作都是如此。看看篮球运动员，一个篮球运动员花大量时间做签名、找经纪人、参加各种图书签名会或T恤签名会，所有
this stuff and even more than that and like a lot of time just practicing right so you think of a basketball player it's just playing the game like that you see on tv but in reality they play practice games they do all that stuff you said they talk strategy you're right but even when they're playing basketball they're not playing the kind of basketball you typically think about that's right exactly and so so uh hopefully we give you a taste of sort of what we do day to day. And that kind of kind of helps to helps you to understand sort of what you're in for once you once you do a program, if you're not already doing it for a career. this is a while ago, tell me that they listen to the podcast and they think it's awesome because it's like a conversation with me, but they don't have to participate. That's funny. Okay.
这些事情，甚至更多，还有大量时间只是在练习，对吧？所以你认为篮球运动员只是在电视上打比赛，但实际上他们进行练习赛，做你说的所有那些事情，讨论策略。你是对的。但即使他们在打篮球，他们打的也不是你通常认为的那种篮球。没错，完全正确。所以，希望我们能让你尝尝我们日常工作的滋味。这有助于你了解一旦你从事编程职业，你将面临什么，如果你还没有开始的话。这是很久以前的事了，有人告诉我他们听这个播客，觉得它很棒，因为它就像和我对话，但他们不需要参与。这很有趣。好吧。
So if you're listening, you know who you are. I don't know if that's a backhanded compliment. No, I think they said it's something they like listening to in the background because it's just kind of casual and they know me and they know my taste and they know where I'm going to go nice
所以如果你在听，你知道你是谁。我不知道这算不算是一种反讽的赞美。不，我想他们说这是他们喜欢在后台听的东西，因为它很随意，他们了解我，了解我的品味，也知道我会往哪个方向聊。不错。
that's awesome hello mysterious co-worker keep sending us emails with the feedback and everything we do appreciate it as Patrick said we've answered hopefully all of them if not send us another one another email. And we look forward to hearing what you think about this episode.
那太棒了。你好，神秘的同事。请继续给我们发邮件反馈，我们非常感激。正如Patrick所说，我们希望已经回答了所有问题，如果没有，再给我们发一封邮件。我们期待听到你对这一集的看法。
All right. Until next time. Cool. See you later. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work,
好的。下次见。酷。回头见。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以及重混、改编作品，
but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。